c'est aussi le temps aussi de réfléchir
un peu j'ai l'impression que même jean
miquel toiture mita d'état des regrets
toi tu que tu penses à des trucs pendant
ce que tu disais des choses que j'aurais
pas dû faire est-ce que tu regrettes des
trucs blazy là on serait qu on déconne
mais c'est des trucs aussi qu'on a envie
de se dire est consommé et qu'on se
marre franchement c'est pas tellement
par rapport aux à ma vie amoureuse ce
que je pense qu'on a que ce qu'on mérite
quelque part donc je pense que si je
suis célibataire aujourd'hui c'est
quelque part j'ai bien cherché circo
voilà j'ai été instable j'ai fait des
conneries
donc j'ai mérité qu'on petit voilà où
tiens je quitte pour ça je me plains pas
de ça même si j'espère toujours
retrouver un grand amour
mes romans je réfléchis plutôt assure ma
vie de ma vie par an voilà je n'ai pas
été assez aride est assez présent de
papa pas été assez présent et mes
enfants et je pense particulièrement ce
moment ce que des bois à parce que je
veux pas les risques et décontaminer
bien sûr dont je les vois pas et le la
période me pèse en plus mes enfants et
mes équipes où ai-je petit que voilà
c'est je vais peut-être passer à côté de
quelque chose de très important et ça je
le regrette mais j'ai envie j'ai envie
moi je t'ai vu avec tes enfants
notamment ta fille j'ai l'impression
qu'elle tu en veux pas du tout et
qu'elle est hyper heureuse d'être avec
toi je la vois qu'elle viendrait nous
voir à l'émission
donc est ce que l'on peut reprocher mine
de rien tu voyais trier pas non mais
plus non plus j'ai pris 100 g puce est
absent et mon fils parce que j'étais à
ce moment là je faisais pas de
télévision j'étais aux filles à rosteig
rampante rgp souvent étrangers j'étais
pas là et bijane si je suis parti d'un
ring dakhla et la manne 6 heures on
attend il a 26 ans et voilà et je trouve
qu'il est parti du principe un peu vieux
que un garçon c'est plus rapidement
c'est ce son envol alors que voilà j'ai
à ma fille je suis tout le temps je
laime mais je pense qu'à mon fils je
n'ai jamais dit que je l'aimais alors je
pense évidemment je l'aimais énormément
mais je vais jamais dit peut-être par
pudeur comme j'ai dit à mon père mais
non plus il est parti jusqu'à quand il
était malade à l'hôpital jeunes il faut
que juriste que j'aime et j'ai pas
réussi à lui dire qu'à paris c'est qu'il
le savait j'ai paris je savais que je le
même mais j'ai pas réussi lui dire et
tout ça maintenant je sais qu'avec ma
fille je le corrige sont pas figées
j'essaie de changer parole jean louis
j'ai envie c'est vraiment émouvant ce
que tu sais ce que tu nous raconter tout
libre et c'est pour ça que je t'aime
énormément et parce que tu es quelqu'un
de très sincères et aujourd'hui juste
c'est vrai que toi tu étais extrêmement
sensible et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
je vois tu étais très content d'être
dans l'émission mais est ce que tu
aimerais pas tu aurais pas aimé avoir
quelqu'un avec toi partage et a dit être
amoureux en ce moment pendant ce
confinement ou est ce que c'est bien
comme ça sisi videmment mafieux
c'est ça qui m'a aquila qui a causé la
chute un peu c'est que je suis un peu un
coeur d'artichaut je suis hameau de
l'amour mais qu'on amoureux de l'amour
en général ça dure pas très longtemps
parce qu'on est on est passionnel et du
conte se lasse assez vite et c'est
l'histoire qui durent pas très longtemps
mais c'est sûr que je me dis que la nd
seul c'est pas c'est pas la meilleure
des solutions j'ai vu en trois semaines
vous savez combien de temps donné qu'on
finit presque un mois personne
j'ai vu une personne c'est jimmy mohamed
qui est venu chez moi s'est engagé en un
mois mais vos maîtres qui sera avec mon
travail mais c'est la seule personne que
j'ai vu qui est venu chez moi c'est lui
avec sa famille - porte une sud team sur
thur à ces gens tu regrettes mine de
rien ne pas avoir dit des choses plutôt
à tes enfants tu avais envie de leur
dire plus je t'aime tout ça parce que tu
m'as les pouvoirs j'espère bien sûr mais
bien sûr bien sûr je vais la voir mais
je le sais je dis ça mais je le regrette
encore parce que quand je vois mon fils
je lui dis pas alors je le pense mais je
me force à l'écrire par texto par texto
je lui dis plus de choses mais on de
vive voix j'ai plus de machines
anciennes l'ancienne génération c c'est
pas naturel chez moi ce bilan est ton
témoignage sur ton papa était était très
fort bonjour merci en tout cas des têtes
d'être aussi aussi franc et donner
autant de choses dans l'émission j'ai
bien sûr qu'on t'aime aussi barré
kouteiba têtu et qu'on t'aime fort